there was an earthquake a couple days
ago their life respect my house was
spooky when it happen because I got a
kid and a lot of little baby toys a
motion sensor so that when he picks them
up they start singing at you right I
know so like the house felt like it kind
it just for like seconds with like that
and then the house started going welcome
to my learning show we want to show you
do you like that right there's another
bear in the corner going I love you it
was like out of his Steven Spielberg
filming little things are crawling oh if
he wrote that it'd be like I've gone too
far that is too scary yeah that really
happened it really happened he my mother
was upset why well because not worth
quakes in Australia are you parents
living my parents are living but not
good my parents and don't know if
they've ever truly lived they hate each
other yeah you know they hate each other
they still marry yeah sit there I
suspect my dad goes to prostitutes if
there's a lot
no probs there's a lot going on here -
my mother's favorite sentences that in
the world is I have a parent should
never outlive their child oh my god God
if I could die like John Belushi or
something that that would be the first
time my mother had come in 30 40 this
should be the whole exercise gross this
yeah
Mel this is about therapy I've had me is
some primo right here